hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
in this session we'll discuss binomial
distribution
which is an important topic of
probability distribution
let's discuss what's in it for you
we'll start this tutorial by discussing
the important terms that you should know
then we'll move on to discuss binomial
distribution and the formula for
calculating the binomial coefficient
then we'll work on an example to get the
clear understanding of the topic so
let's get started
basics and terminology
the first one is outcome
whenever we do an experiment like
flipping a coin or rolling a dice we get
an outcome for example if we flip a coin
we get an outcome of heads or tails and
if we roll a die we get an outcome of 1
2 3 4 5 or 6.
random experiment
a random experiment is any well-defined
procedure that produces an observable
outcome that could not be perfectly
predicted in advance
a random experiment
must be well defined to eliminate any
vagueness or surprise
it must produce a definite observable
outcome so that you know what happened
after the random experiment is run
random events
consider a simple example
let us say that we toss a coin up in the
air
what can happen when it gets back it
either gives a head or a tail
these two are known as outcome and the
occurrence of an outcome is an event
thus the event is the outcome of some
phenomenon
the last one is sample space
a sample space is a collection or a set
of possible outcomes of a random
experiment
the sample space is represented using
the symbol s
the subset of all possible outcomes of
an experiment is called events and a
sample space may contain a number of
outcomes that depends on the experiment
if it contains a finite number of
outcomes then it is known as a discrete
or finite sample spaces
now let's discuss what is random
variable
a random variable is a numerical
description of the outcome of a
statistical experiment
a random variable that may assume only a
finite number of values is said to be
discrete
one that may assume any value in some
interval on the real number line is said
to be continuous
let's see an example
let x be a random variable defined as
the sum of numbers when two dices are
rolled
x can assume the values 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 and 12.
notice there is no one here because the
sum of the two dice can never be one
now that we know the basics let's move
on to binomial distribution
the binomial distribution is used when
there are exactly two mutually exclusive
outcomes of a trial
these outcomes are appropriately labeled
success and failure
the binomial distribution is used to
obtain the probability of observing x
successes in n number of trials
with the probability of success on a
single trial denoted by p
the binomial distribution assumes that p
is fixed for all the trials
here is a real life example of a
binomial distribution
suppose you purchase a lottery ticket
then either you are going to win the
lottery or not in other words the
outcome will be either success or
failure that can be proved through
binomial distribution
there are four important conditions that
needs to be fulfilled for an experiment
to be a binomial experiment
the first one is there should be a fixed
number of entries carried out
the outcome of a given trial
is only two that is either a success or
a failure
the probability of success remains
constant from trial to trial it does not
changes from one trial to another
and the trials are independent the
outcome of a trial is not affected by
the outcome of any other trial
to calculate the binomial coefficient we
use the formula which is ncr into p to
the power r into 1 minus p
to the power n minus r where r is the
number of success in n number of trials
and p is the probability of success 1
minus p denotes the probability of a
failure
now let's use this formula to solve an
example
suppose a die is tossed 3 times what is
the probability of no 5 turning up 1 5
and 3 5 is turning out
to calculate the no 5 turning up here r
is equal to 0 and n is equal to 3
substituting the value in the formula we
have 3 c 0 into 1 by 6 to the power 0
into 5 by 6 to the power 3 where 1 by 6
is the probability of success and 5 by 6
is the probability of failure
calculating this equation will get the
value to be 0.5787
in a similar manner to calculate the
probability of 1 5 turning up we'll
replace r with 1 and n will be 3 so p x
1 will be equal to 3 c 1 into 1 by 6 to
the power 1 into 5 by 6 to the power 2
which will come out to be 0.347
and for 3 5 turning up we substitute r
equal to 3 and the formula will remain
the same and we will get the value to be
0.0046
now that we are done with the concepts
of animal probability distribution here
is a problem for you to solve
post your answers in the comment section
and let us know
so with this we have come to an end of
this tutorial thank you all for watching
this session we hope you enjoyed it
if you have any questions feel free to
put them in the comment section of this
video thank you again and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here